getting transparency inside a company is
really critical but if the people
running the company don't have a sense
of what all of the people around the
company are worried about um then you're
not gonna be able to run the company as
best as possible and so that's why i do
things like every week i run a an open q
a and just that way anyone can come and
ask me any question but it's not only
that
we try to make it so that we encourage
people to ask the hardest possible
questions
we create a poll in advance and people
can submit questions and people can vote
on them and they can do that anonymously
um so that way uh
where i i can make sure every week that
i know what the top issues are that
people are worried about inside the
company and that i can address that and
we certainly have a pretty flat
management culture we're not generally
very hierarchical
you know i talk to a lot of my product
managers and engineers and just go
through many layers of management
because i want to hear what's going on
and
that's just that's how we try to operate
the company and i think that's very
important